over lakers have numbers three on two
ayahi with the lane yeah lakers playing
tremendous off their defense
aggressive brown has been a factor look
at him push up and pressure right now
a little too overzealous
he blew his shoe off he did
he blew out the tire
it came out the side of his foot
so we're all thinking about that zion
incident down at duke when he did the
same thing
he came right through the side of his
shoe wow
he was up pressuring their defensive
intensity is
noticeable here in the second quarter
right
and he kept playing too doris love it
hey sometimes it's like when you blow a
flat you got to make it to the next
service station
now does he have a spare tire over there
i can tell he's disappointed
he does he not have an extra pair is
that why he's throwing that down
come on you can't be done for the night
because you blew a tire you gotta
check somebody in the stands or some of
your
some of your friends somewhere put a
9-1-1 out
get another pair of kicks
geez
topping
tipped up his miss three for a quarter
he missed them all